hello YouTube this is international
master Eric Rosen
and welcome to my first ever
instructional chess youtube video I'm
hoping to do many more over the coming
weeks and months and if it's if it's
something that the online audience likes
all work to put out videos on on a
weekly or even daily basis so the first
first series of topics I'm going to
cover are just opening tricks and
opening traps and we'll we'll get much
deeper into openings and I'll take your
questions and if there's any openings
that you want me to cover in my videos
please let me know in the comments or
feel free to send me a message
the first one it's gonna be short and
sweet and it's an opening trap in the
Scandinavian being where white plays
efore and black plays d5 and this is a
bit lesser-known of a trap which I've
seen people walk into it pretty much all
levels I've had actually a grandmaster
walk into this against me on an online
Bullock game and I won in about 12 moves
as whites so hopefully people can can
take this learn it and use it in their
own games so the line I recommend is
very simple take take 93 point 85 and
the move to play here is a bit risky
looking at first but I think it's the
very venomous move and it's a type of
move that black won't won't be too
familiar with especially for slightly
less experienced players so the move is
before simply sacrificing a pawn for for
a lot more active play and black is
pretty much obliged to take the pawn if
black is scared and doesn't want to take
it plays a move like Queen b6 white's is
simply controlling more space on the
Queen side and something along the lines
maybe of rook b1 and reinforce the D
pawn or even just continuing development
with some moves like Knight of three
would suffice for white but most of the
time black will take the bait
take on before and now white plays a
very kind of tricky move and it's not
the type of move that you would perhaps
guess movies might be five moving the
same piece twice but but taking over an
initiative
so very simple threat of I take c7 and
black is forced to defend in some way
and most people will play Queen a5 here
this is typically the most natural
response on keeping the Queen safe
defending the C pawn there's not too
many other options for her black if
Queen c5 is played that would just walk
into d4 and white gets some serious
initiative against the Queen because the
queen is always tied down to the C pawn
and this is something that black doesn't
really want to get into for example
Queen c6 would walk into d5 I'm cycling
back to c5 I think white is already
winning after Bishop e3 and if I'm not
mistaken is a queen trapped now that
Queens not rats but after Queen Queen
before C 3.85 maybe White's not winning
but okay this position looks very very
nice for whites so let's go back to the
main line say Queen a5 and in this
position white will play very
natural-looking development developing
move but it's a very nasty threat to it
the move is Bishop to c4 and if flack is
careless or just tactically blinds and
doesn't see the threats then white can
pretty much win the game right away so
the common mistakes for black in this
position are either playing a6 or c6
both of which pretty much lose right
away let's say let's say blacks 86 this
is what most people are inclined to do
simply trying to force a knight to move
back and now White has a pretty cool
tactical shots and if you want to find
it feel free to pause your videos so the
move is Bishop take s7 very simply uh or
maybe not simply aha sacrificing a
bishop
but taking advantage of the kind of
tactical geometry in the position so
let's say black ticks and now after
queen h5 should start making sense as
the Queen's are now aligned on the fifth
rank and lights is winning a lot of
material so for example if g6 and simply
96 and usually at this point black is
realizing that the queen is going
bye-bye so another option for black
would be psyching Essex but if we just
look at the the King position in this
situation lights is white should be very
happy I can continue as and move like
Bishop to b2 and notice that the King
can never move to a square which can be
attacked by the Knights so I move like
he knew six with again walking to moving
the Queen so the move that box would
probably try and play as a move like a
five but after let's say queen take Oh
black is just getting kicked around
basically like a punching bag
if King F 796 winning the Queen if King
g6 Queenie eights and light can munch on
a bunch of pieces on the back rank for
example of King h6 Queen to f8 and white
will win no problem so if we go back to
the the key move B for its it's an
aggressive opening and very easy for
black to stumble into this trick because
it looks like Black was just playing
normal moves but turns out c6 it's a
very bad mistake let's say black doesn't
fall into the trap and let's say black
plays perhaps a better move like a 600
take f7 y can kind of play this like a
Danish cabbage where yes White's down
down upon but move like Bishop to b2 I
think gives light some nice compensation
for for the pawn deficit because the two
bishops can be very powerful in this
position and there's a lot of
opportunities for light to attack not
only on the Kings side but also to kick
around
like you're the black Queen perhaps a
bit later on so I hope you you guys
enjoyed that I'll be putting out a lot
more videos similar to this if you have
any questions or you want to recommend
some topic for me to cover feel free to
comment and feel free to like the video
if you enjoyed it and I will see you in
the next video